[MUSIC PLAYING]
DOMINIC PREUSS: Good
afternoon, everyone.
My name is Dominic Preuss.
I'm the director
and product manager
for our storage databasing
capacity products
on Google Cloud Platform.
So I'm very excited to
be here today, day three
of this amazing conference, to
talk about database migration
service on GCP.
As we've onboarded more and more
large enterprise customers--
we've talked about
Target in the keynote.
We've talked about HSBC
and other large companies.
They often have a
dilemma about how
to get their data
into the cloud.
And so we have a set
of recommendations
we give to people when they
think about these migrations.
So the first thing is, as
customers are moving their data
into the cloud, we want to make
sure that they're realizing
value all the way along.
So we want to make
sure that they identify
which workloads to move
first, get on track,
get some experience,
get comfortable
moving data data into
the cloud, and then
that allows you to minimize the
disruption to your business.
So we'll take you through
kind of a framework
of how we talk about that
and how we think about it.
And then I'll bring
up Yair from Alooma
to talk about how they
do database migrations.
So when we go in and talk to
large customers about database
migration, we focus on three
phases of the approach.
The first one is assessment.
This is where you actually
look at the data that you have,
think about what would
be most logical to move.
And then we move
into phase two, which
is doing the actual migration.
So we'll talk about some
strategies for doing migration.
And the last one is validation.
How do you know that your
migration was successful?
Phase one-- assessment.
The first question is, what
apps and databases need to move?
One of the things that's
most interesting about my job
is going into customers.
And they say, I need to
move some data to the cloud.
I say great.
What data do you have?
They're like, I don't know.
So I think, OK, the
first thing we need to do
is go through and
actually catalog
and do some discovery on
all of your databases.
Once we have the full
list of databases,
we can look at which ones
might be appropriate to move
to the cloud.
And this might be based on
which databases actually
work well in the cloud, which
ones have managed services.
So you're going to look
at what is the match
or mismatch of your databases to
what's available in the cloud.
Once you've identified what
some of those database workloads
are that might
move to the cloud,
you need to understand
the capabilities that
are out there.
One of the things that we see
is often a really big issue
is, if you're running older
versions of databases,
it's often more difficult
to move those to the cloud.
If you have an older version
of MySQL or Postgres,
you might not be able to
move that into Cloud SQL,
because it doesn't
support the same version.
And so then you might
not be able to take
advantage of a managed service.
And you might have
to actually put that
on to a GCE, a Google
Compute Engine VM,
and manage that yourself.
So you have to make sure
that the capabilities that
are available in the platform
match with the use cases
that you have.
Then you have to
figure out what is
the right path for the cloud.
So if you're moving a
database or an application,
can that database or
application accept downtime?
Do you have to basically try to
do a live failover migration,
or can you accept an hour
or two hours of downtime?
Can you do it over a weekend?
Can you do it overnight?
What are the actual requirements
of that application when you
want to move it into the cloud?
And the last one is,
how will does the target
support the application?
You might want to move
an application that
has a MySQL database.
And that MySQL database might
be supported by Cloud SQL,
so you can move
that database over.
But for some reason,
that application
requires something that doesn't
work well in the public cloud.
Maybe it only runs
on bare metal.
Maybe it requires
some APIs or access
to underlying systems that
make it inappropriate to run
in the public cloud.
So you need to make sure that
the target of where you want
to land your
database matches what
you need from that
application and database.
Phase two is the migration.
What you want to do is
once you've identified
the applications and workloads
that you want to migrate,
you need to figure out what type
of migration am I going to do.
So this is actually using the
Gartner set of migration types.
And we've actually
added one, because we
think they forgot the most
important one, which is retire.
The first thing you should do
is look at all your databases.
And the first thing
you should say
is, do I still
need this database?
Are people using it?
Can it be consolidated?
Can it be basically retired?
So do I even need
to migrate that?
We think that's a very
important first step.
The second one is replace.
Another thing you need to
do is look at your database.
So let's say that you're running
an on-premise CRM solution that
has a MySQL database.
So your first question is, do
I want to migrate to the cloud,
or do I just want to
move to a Saas offering?
Do I just move to Salesforce?
Do I move to a
fully-hosted solution?
If I'm moving
Exchange Server, do I
want to go to a hosted
exchange offering?
Do I need to move
those databases at all,
or can I move to a
full Saas offering?
That's option number two.
Number three is rehost.
So this is basically
moving that application
and hosting it on GCE VMs.
So when you move that
data over, can you
put it on to a [? Pas ?]
offering, which
is option number four.
If I can't, can
I run it on a VM?
So again, things that end
up being really interesting
here are really old
versions of databases,
less common databases.
So if you have something
like a MarkLogic,
or if you're running a
Neo4j or something that
doesn't have a manage offering
today, can you put it on a VM
and manage it yourself?
And so that's option number
two, which is rehost.
The next one is refactor.
When I talk about our customers
that are coming to the cloud,
I find that they break
out into two camps.
There's a set of people who
have the right people in-house,
feel very comfortable
and want to manage
their own infrastructure.
So they want to come,
and they'll actually
use our IS offerings, our
infrastructures service.
But what we find is
about 80% of people
are coming to us because
they're having trouble managing.
They're having trouble
hiring the people that
are necessary to
manage their workloads.
Or they're having
some other reason
that they don't want to
manage infrastructure anymore.
So they have a very
strong incentive
to try to move to our platform
as a service offerings--
Cloud SQL, our memory
store offering for Redis,
those types of things.
They want to get out of
the business of managing
their infrastructure.
So the question is, can
they move on to our platform
as a service offering,
another layer up the stack?
The next one is revise.
The first three assume that
you're not making any changes
to the application.
You're basically picking
up your application as is,
running it exactly the same way,
and putting it in the cloud.
The next one is
revise and modernize.
So this is, can you
make some changes
to your application to take
better advantage of the cloud?
So an example is I
have an application.
It's currently
running on MySQL 55.
That's not offered in Cloud SQL.
Can I upgrade that
application to use 56 or 57,
so now, I can move
that into Cloud SQL?
Or I have an
internal application.
It currently uses Postgres.
I'm about to go out of
my Postgres instance.
I'd really like to
move to Cloud Spanner.
Can I actually re-platform that
and rewrite that application
to work on top of our
platform as a service?
And the last one is rebuild.
If I have an application, it
might be long in the tooth.
It's missing a bunch
of requirements.
I'm just going to rebuild
the whole application.
And now, you're in
Greenfield, and you're not
migrating anything.
And now, you can
actually rebuild
using some of our cloud
native technologies,
like Kubernetes, [? SDO ?]
the Cloud Services Platform
and actually take advantage
of the full power of the cloud
if you actually rewrite the
application from scratch.
So these are really
the six different ways.
So it's the five from
Gardner, plus we've
added retire, which we think
is a very useful migration,
for people that are
moving to the cloud.
Then you get to the
validation step,
and this is really important.
Once you've moved
the data, you need
to verify that that
data has come across.
Now this might be as simple
as doing a count select star
on all of your tables to
make sure that they're
the same number of rows
and the old database
is in the new database.
Depending on which
database technology,
you can do check sums
on the data to make sure
that the data has come across.
But you really need to make sure
that that data has come over
wholly.
Then you want to do is
then start to optimize.
So you want to look at, OK,
those MySQL database flags
that I was using
on-premise, should I
be using the same
flags in the cloud?
Probably not.
You probably want to use
a different set of flags
to optimize for a
particular workload
when running in
the public cloud.
We also want to do some
performance checks.
So obviously, once you
have all the data over,
and you've checked
all your tuning,
you want to make sure that you
are having an acceptable level
of performance.
You want to make sure that
something hasn't changed
with the way that you're hosting
it on-premise, in the cloud.
You want to make sure that
your customers are still
happy with the level of
latency and performance
that you're delivering
from the system.
So these are the
general framework
that we think about when we
talk about database migrations.
And so how does Google
Cloud Platform help?
So the first thing is
we provide a foundation.
All of our services on
Google Cloud Platform
are industry-leading in
terms of performance,
whether it be our VMs
with persistent disk,
whether it be Cloud
Bigtable or Cloud SQL.
And so we have a
strong foundation
that scales, gives you
industry-leading performance,
and also gives you
industry-leading networking.
And so whenever you are
doing these migrations,
the thing that ends up
always being the thing
that you get stuck on
is actually networking.
How do you get network
connectivity from on-premise
into the cloud.
How do you get in that kind of
activity from your application
into the database.
So all of the tools that we
provide around networking
actually are key enablers of
doing database migrations.
It also helps when you can
get the bytes there faster
over the network.
For the capabilities--
a number of features.
We're going to talk
about our external master
feature in Cloud SQL.
Today, we also have
a number of tools
that we're working
on and then partners.
We spent a lot of time
over the last year, year
and a half building out
the partner ecosystem.
So working with partners,
like Alooma and other partners
in the space, to make sure that
all of those tools that you're
used to using on-premise
or in other public clouds
work great on Google
Cloud Platform.
And so you can use whatever
tool you're used to using.
We don't want to force you
on any particular tool.
We don't want to tell you
how to do your migrations.
If you have a tool that
you're used to using,
we want to make sure that
we have a great partnership
with that partner, a great
relationship with that partner
to make sure that
that tool works.
And the last one is support.
So obviously, enterprise--
great support.
We now have two different
types of enterprise support.
There's the first, which is
the cost base, where you get
different levels of support.
And then we've gone to a roll
base, where you can basically
pay for individual
seats of support,
depending on what's
better for your customer.
What's better for
you as a customer
and what's better for
your cost structure.
And then lastly, we offer a
number of enterprise support
mechanisms.
We have our professional
services organization.
We spent a lot of time
talking about what
the professional
services organization
that we've built at Google that
can help you with these things.
Obviously, the SRE books are a
Site Reliability Engineer team.
We published the original site
reliability engineering book,
and we just published the second
book, which is the workbook.
And then our CMEs, which are our
Customer Reliability Engineers.
This is really interesting.
If you are moving
a large application
or if you're launching
a large application,
you can engage with our Customer
Reliability Engineering team.
And they will sit down with you
and talk through your launch
plan, your Runbooks, how are
you going to support an outage,
how are you going to deal with
the various things that could
go wrong when you do a launch.
So we provide all of
these services for people
to be able to take
advantage of as they
are migrating that application
or launching new applications.
We talked a little
bit about tooling.
Now, we're going to talk
about migration to Cloud SQL.
One of the most
common patterns we
see when people are moving
relational databases
to the cloud is this model
where, basically, you
have a MySQL database
that is managed somewhere.
This might be on-premise.
It might be on
another public cloud.
But that's where your master is.
And so the easiest way to get
your data into Google Cloud
Platform is to add a replica
of that database in Cloud SQL.
So in this case, for
Cloud SQL for MySQL,
basically, you can add
a Cloud SQL replica
that is speaking to a master
instance, a master node that
is somewhere else.
So this way, you can
replicate all of your data
into Google Cloud Platform using
MySQL's native replication.
So you get all of the
consistency guarantees
and all the things that
are possible through MySQL
via asynchronous
replication, so you're not
impacting your performance, to
get your data into the cloud.
Once it's into the cloud, you
can then add a failover replica
so that you have HA.
And then you can basically
trigger a failover
to then move the application
from speaking to your master
instance that is somewhere else
to the Cloud SQL replica, which
was a read-only replica, which
is now your master replica.
And you have HA by
having a second replica
where that data is managed.
So now, you've moved all of
your data from another location
into Google Cloud Platform.
You've now replicated it so
that it's highly available.
And now, you can
repoint your application
to take advantage
of that new setup.
One of the things that
we advocate always
whenever we're doing a migration
of an application or database
is that we really encourage
people to take the simplest
possible approach.
It's very easy to
boil the ocean when
you're trying to move data.
So it's very
important that you try
to start with the simplest
possible [? implementation. ?]
The vast majority of databases--
usually this is around 80%
of all of the databases--
you can move very simply
with some downtime.
Basically, you have an
existing database instance.
You stop writes
to that database.
Reads can continue to come in.
You export that data.
So if it's MySQL, it's a SQL
[? dom. ?] It could be CSV.
It could be whatever
data format.
You copy that data into
Google Cloud Storage.
And then, using Cloud
SQL or whichever
database you're using,
import that data in, and then
move the database across.
So this is by far the simplest
way of moving your data across.
Now this might be
an hour of downtime.
It might be two hours,
depending how much data.
But if you're dealing with
hundred gigabytes of data,
smaller data sets, then this
is a very acceptable way
of doing this.
If your application can be down
overnight or over the weekend,
this is by far the simplest
way to do a database migration.
Now the key factor in
that migration scenario
that I just gave you
is how long does it
take to take that import and
put it into the new thing?
So if you are copying
the data-- you've
done an export of your
database-- copying it
into Google Cloud Storage
because our network tends
to be very fast.
The long pole of this
process is basically
how long it takes to get your
data from Google Cloud Storage
into your target
database, whether that be
Cloud SQL or Cassandra,
whatever it happens to be.
So here's some
general best practices
that we try to explain to people
when importing database data.
So the first thing is,
when you import your data,
don't include your indexes.
Bring your data across.
Bring the raw data.
Don't try to bring over
all your secondary indexes
at the same time.
Import your data first and then
add your secondary indexes.
This dramatically
lowers the amount
of import time for
most databases.
The second thing is
do your best to import
the data in primary key order.
Try to make sure
that your export
is ordered by primary key.
So that when you're
importing the data,
it makes it as easy as
possible for the database
to insert that data.
If you are using
MySQL or Postgres--
and MySQL specifically--
it's really important that you
select a instance type that
has as much RAM as at
least your largest table,
if not your entire dataset.
By bringing all that data in on
a really large memory instance,
you basically can keep
all of the data in memory.
And it makes it much easier
to write the data in.
So use a much larger memory
size instance initially.
Then you might need
to run production.
You can always
downsize it later.
And so this will really
speed up the import process
and decrease the
downtime that you
have in the database migration.
The second thing is
use our SSD storage.
Persistent disk, our
block storage device,
comes in two flavors--
magnetic disk and solid state.
And so if you're importing into
a GCE VM or into Cloud SQL,
using this option will
dramatically speed up
your imports into the system.
Another thing to
remember is when
you're using persistent
disk, the amount
of IOPS you get on your disk
are dependent to the size
of the disks.
So make sure you use at
least a 500 gigabyte disk
to make sure you're getting the
maximum throughput on that VM.
And lastly, make sure
you're monitoring.
You can watch things
like IOPS, whether this
be from your GCE VM or if this
is in your Cloud SQL instance.
You can do this via the cloud
console or via Stackdriver.
And then obviously, keep an
eye on your read operations.
Because very high
read operations
might indicate
that your database
is paging, which will basically
increase your import time.
So these are all things
to think about when you're
importing the data to try to
minimize the downtime when
you're migrating.
And then after
you import, again,
because you're in the
cloud, you haven't
bought a physical device
that you can't resize,
you can resize your database,
make it bigger or smaller.
You can turn on the binary
logging as necessary.
Turning this off ahead
of time in Cloud SQL
will dramatically increase
your import times.
And then add your
indexes after the fact.
Don't add indexes when you
are importing the data.
Add them after the fact.
It's much, much faster and will
save you a tremendous amount
of import time.
Now if you're moving
an application that
can't accept
downtime, you're going
to want to look at using
replication to actually
move your data across.
As we talked about
here, you're actually
moving the data across.
We're going to replace
that step with actually
doing replication.
Now if you're
doing like-to-like,
if you're doing MySQL to MySQL,
Postgres to Postgres, Cassandra
to Cassandra, you can basically
use the native replication.
If you're doing something
like MySQL to Postgres,
or you're doing a
heterogeneous migration, then
some of the tools,
like Attunity, Alooma,
some of the other partners
can help you really
with that workload.
Because they can
provide you replication
that isn't native replication.
So the idea here is that
you're replicating all the data
across.
And then once the new
instance has caught up,
and you know that the
lag is sufficient--
if this can't ever
catch up, you might
have to stop writes for
a small amount of time
while that replication
catches up.
But assuming you can
get to a steady state
where there's very
little lag, then
you basically can move your
application over and have
it speak to the other instance.
And therefore, you can have
very low downtime migrations.
Another workload that
we talk about a lot
is migrating Cassandra to Cloud
Bigtable or Cloud Spanner.
For this talk, we're going
to focus on Bigtable mostly
because there's lots of Cloud
Spanner sessions talking
about migration.
One of the most common use
cases we see for Cloud Bigtable
is people wanting to
migrate off of their H base
of their Cassandra clusters.
So we see this as a
very common use case
for people moving
to Cloud Bigtable.
One of the big questions is,
if I'm coming off of Cassandra,
should I use Cloud Bigtable
or should I use Cloud Spanner?
So we put together a
little bit of information
to help you choose
between the two.
Because Cassandra has a very
wide variety of use cases,
and so how you're
using Cassandra
will determine which
cloud service you want.
So you want to
use Cloud Bigtable
if you're serving
derived data or if you're
doing batch ingested analytics.
If you're using it as a
true wide column store,
and you're trying to write data
in and use it as an analytics
cluster, then Cloud
Bigtable's going
to be a better solution for you.
If you're serving user
visible and mutatable data,
especially if you have
multi-row transactions
or you need secondary
indexes, then you're
going to want to
use Cloud Spanner.
A way to think about
this is, if you
are using Cassandra
with the local quorum
to write to a
single zone cluster
with eventual consistency,
then Cloud Bigtable
is probably the right
solution for you
and will give you cost
advantage over Cloud Spanner.
If you're using Spanner with
each quorum or local quorums,
but it spans multiple
regions in the ring,
then you're going to want
to use Cloud Spanner to get
the same level of functionality.
So how do we do this?
You have an application that's
speaking to your Cassandra
cluster.
The most common way that
we see customers migrating
and what we recommend is what
we call a dual write structure.
So basically, you have
an application that's
writing to some sort of queue.
This could be a Kafka queue.
It could be RabbitMQ.
It might be some place on your
application where you hold.
And then basically, we recommend
that you do tool writes.
So you have two consumers
of that queue that
write the data to both Cassandra
and either Bigtable or Spanner.
So what this does is it allows
you to basically write data
to both databases while
the application is
talking to Cassandra.
Once you've gotten a
sufficient amount of data
into the Cassandra cluster
and it is caught up,
then you can look at moving it
into and switching the path.
So here, if you don't want
to run your own consumers,
you could use Cloud Data Flow.
You use Dataproc to do this.
You could also use
Cloud Functions
or some of our other
serverless architectures.
We talked about Kafka.
Some suggestions-- you can use
Apache Kafka if your writes
are non-idempotent.
I always get this word wrong.
This is one of the most
difficult words for me to say.
If you need in-order message
delivering is required
or if you need compatibility
with the existing Kafka
tool, Kafka [? Screen, ?] or
whatever it happens to be.
You can use Cloud Data Flow if
your writes are idempotent--
try that again-- or out of
order message delivery is OK
or it needs to be
globally replicated.
So then once you've gotten
all the data written over,
you've done an export to
kind of get the bulk data,
and then you've done
a written, now, you
can actually move
your application
to speak to Cloud Bigtable and
start to read the applications.
You're still doing
writes to both places,
so you can roll back.
But now, you can read the data
from your new database source.
Then you're mission
accomplished.
The migration is done.
All right, so with
that, I would like
to bring up somebody who
has much more experience
than I do at
database migrations.
So I'll bring up Yair
Weinberger, the CTO
and co-founder of Alooma
to share some of the tools
that they provide.
[APPLAUSE]
YAIR WEINBERGER:
Thank you, Dominic.
Can you hear me?
My mic all right?
So I'm Yair, CTO of
Alooma, as I mentioned.
And we deal with
migrations all the time.
And a lot of it is
to [? GCP ?] as well.
And I'm going to talk
a little bit more
in depth about
database migration,
especially the more complex use
cases and things you can enter.
But before that, just a little
bit about generally Alooma
and data migration.
I'm sure this is not
news to any one of you.
We used to be on-prem.
We used to have our
compute on-prem.
We use to have our storage
on-prem, our database on-prem.
And what happens now
is we want to move.
We want to move to
modern technology.
We want to manage the
service in the cloud.
We want to use the best
of [? free ?] technologies
for every one of our
workloads, our applications
are moving to containers.
Our storage is moving to
the cloud storage, which
is infinite and much cheaper.
And then our databases are also
moving to the cloud databases.
And this is what
Alooma is about.
And what I didn't mention is
that new applications are just
born in the cloud.
It's very easy.
We create it inside a container.
We use Cloud SQL, and
we just let it fly,
and it's just working
out-of-the-box.
But whenever we are looking at
a little bit bigger company,
it has a lot of
legacy applications.
Some of them, the
people who wrote
the code don't exist anymore
or don't work for the company.
Some of them has a lot of legacy
databases, petabyte of data.
I think one of the
[? fanfics ?] was
how to move over three petabytes
of data only to be moved.
This is that dragon
need to be tamed.
And everyone who experienced
that knows it can be extremely
difficult and time--consuming.
Sometimes even takes years.
So just saying I want
to move to the cloud
can be quite difficult.
When migrating, there are
three types of migration.
And I'm going to focus
on the data migration
part, which is what Alooma
is focused on as well.
There is the compute instances.
We want to move our
compute and workload
to the cloud, our
applications and services,
and the data itself.
Now because this
process is not atomic,
it's not like we
can start on-prem,
and then the next day, we
are fully in the cloud.
It takes time.
It can take months.
It can takes years.
While we make that move, not
only we want to move the data,
but we want to keep the
two environments in sync.
We want to make sure
whatever we have on-prem
can be synced to whatever we
have in the cloud and sometimes
even back, sometimes
even vice versa.
And that's where
Alooma comes in.
Alooma have built the tooling
and the product as a service
in the cloud to migrate out
of the on-premise data from
databases, from storage, from
data centers, enterprise,
data warehouses into the cloud--
actually all clouds, but
Google in that context.
So how does a migration
data pipeline look like?
This is a little bit of
a peek under the hood.
You need to have a
lot of connectors,
connect to anything.
And that could be RDBMS, which
is the focus of this talk today
and what I am going to show
soon how we migrate a database
instance.
But that also could be files
that can exist on FTP servers,
on servers, on some
cloud storage that we
might have put in there.
That could be event streams
are coming from mobile devices,
coming from applications.
And they can even be the
Saas vendors that we use.
Because already, not all of our
application are inside the org.
Some of them we use Salesforce.
We use [? Marketo ?] hubs.
But all of those
new Saas vendors,
we want to make sure we are able
to read their data as well, so
a lot of connectors.
And then once we get
all of that data in,
we, of course, put it
in the message queue.
Alooma, under the
hood, uses Kafka.
But that's, of
course, non-mandatory.
We do believe it is
currently one of the best
options in the market.
We want to be able to
transform or modify
the data that goes through.
And that's what we
call the code engine.
They're built to run
code on the data that
goes through the stream.
And we want to be able to
know how the data looks like,
what is the schema.
So again, I'm sure many of you
have used Hadoop in the past
and are familiar with the schema
on read concept, where we just
push everything
into that data lake
and then take care of the schema
when we want to read the data.
I believe that this has
created a lot of problem.
Because sometimes, the
schema changes over time.
The schema is [? askew. ?] And
if we only find out about it
when we try to read the data,
we might be in big trouble
already.
So we need to understand
and maintain the schema
or how the data look like.
And it can be either
imported from the source
or inferred from
the data itself.
So if we read data from Oracle
database or anything that
has a schema with
it, that schema
can be imported and translated.
If we're reading data from
files or from event streams,
sometimes the schema needs to be
inferred from the data itself.
And then we need to make
sure we know to put the data
wherever it belongs.
So I want to show you a little
bit lift-and-shift use case.
Can I get the other screen?
Great.
So this is the Alooma product.
And what I want to show you
is how we take database MySQL
on-prem--
looks like I will
need my VPN here.
Sorry about that.
And take that and move
it to a MySQL Cloud SQL
instance in the cloud.
And I actually want to add a
little bit of a twist here.
Because as Dominic
said, sometimes there
are just very simple
migration, where we can just
enable replication
between the master on-prem
and whatever the Cloud
SQL we have in the cloud
and let the MySQL
application take care of it.
But I want to introduce
another very common concept
of sharding.
My on-premise
databases is sharded.
And I'm writing to
two different shards.
But there is no need
to keep the sharding
when I'm moving to Cloud SQL.
When I'm moving to
Cloud SQL, of course,
I can make the
instances much bigger.
I already have highly
available out of the box.
So I want to data sharding.
And I want to write everything
to the same database instance.
It makes my applications
more maintainable.
It makes my querying the
data more maintainable,
because I don't need to
query for multiple shards.
So there is a little
bit of a twist.
If I just enable
replication as is,
I will keep the
sharding in place.
So what do I do here?
I started my Cloud SQL instance
of MySQL, which is here.
And I configure it as
a target for Alooma.
So very simple, I configure
the same cloud SQL
as the target for Alooma.
And then, that I already did,
but the next thing I need to do
is just to add the MySQL
data source or sources.
So this is, again, very simple.
And, by the way,
that can be Oracle.
That can be pretty much any
cloud database, SQL Server,
Postgres.
So I can also do lift and
shift or lift and modernize
the same way.
In that case, if I take MySQL,
then all I need to provide
is the connection details,
the type of replication.
Of course,
[INAUDIBLE] to capture
is the most recommended one.
But it can be incremental
application or full dump
load replication as well and
the list of tables to replicate.
Of course, I can
leave that empty.
And then it just means I'm
shifting my entire database.
I don't want to just move a
specific subset of tables.
Once I got that done,
once that is configured,
I have my data
running and streaming.
I can click on it.
I can see live samples, whatever
comes through the stream.
So in that case, I've made
a very simple use case.
I have my on-prem database.
I have two shards, which
are in one table, which
is transactions.
And every shard, there's
only one row in it.
Of course, in reality,
it's much bigger than that.
Once I set up that
connection, what
Alooma will do
under the hood is it
will start replicating the
ongoing changes over time.
And it will create a process
to dump the entire dataset.
And then, no matter if it's
one gigabyte, 10 gigabyte, 100
gigabyte or a
terabyte, that process
will happen under the hood.
It will be optimized to migrate
the data as best as possible.
Take into consideration
the other thing Dominic
mentioned earlier
about re-integrating
that says to import by the
order of primary key, et cetera.
So all of these, you're
already getting that
immediately out of the box.
And then what I also
set up is I just
set up a process that
continuously updates the amount
on my own two orders.
So as I mentioned, we do
want to take those two shards
and put them into one table.
But those shards can have
conflicting primary keys.
Those shards can have the
same primary key in shard one
and shard two.
So what we do is here, we
leverage the Alooma code engine
that I mentioned.
And we change the data as it
is going through the stream.
And that's why we couldn't
use just simple replication.
And it's really a
one line module.
All it does is it takes
the shard from the metadata
that Alooma attached to the data
and put it in the event itself.
So I can actually get live
samples from the data.
In the metadata I have, this
is, like, shard number two.
And now, I'm testing it.
I'm just adding a shard ID
field to the data itself.
And that shard ID, I can
see was added to the data.
So on-prem, we've
seen the data just
has ID created
[? and the amount field. ?]
On the Cloud SQL part, we
do have the shard as well.
So we have shard
one and shard two.
And we have data
from both shards.
And they don't
overwrite each other,
because the shard
is considered to be
as part of the new
primary key on the target.
All right, so we got that going.
It's replicating continuously.
It's very nice.
Now I'm moving my application.
Unfortunately,
again, it's not very
simple to move the application.
Sometimes I cannot move
the application at once.
I need to move the
application in parts.
So what I did was
I moved the part
that only writes to
one of the shards.
So I'm going to change it.
So right now, I'm
updating both shards.
That's my demo application,
which is updating the shards.
Of course, that is
now disconnected.
Let's see if I can
restore it quickly.
This is a real-life demo.
All right, so I was
updating both shards.
Now, I'm only going to
update shard number one.
Because I migrated the
application from shard two,
it only working
directly with Cloud SQL.
So it no longer updates
my on-prem database.
And the only thing that's being
updated in my on-prem database
is shard number one.
However, I also want to make
sure that I'm not wrong.
So I want to make
sure I didn't mess up.
I want to make sure
that there is nothing
left in that
hodgepodge of servers
that I have on-prem that's still
writing to shard two on-prem.
I want to be confident and
validate that I actually
did the migration successfully.
So what I'm going to
do is I'm going just
to add another small
cotangent piece in the model
that I created.
I'm just going to commentate
that out, which says, OK,
if I'm reading data
from shard number two,
let's raise an exception.
Let's say, OK, I'm
not allowing anymore
[? outage ?] on
shard number two.
That will give me two things.
One, it will give me the
visibility that it happened.
But it will also stop
the data from moving,
because I probably don't
want that data moving.
Now I can also move that later.
But for now, I want to
stop it from moving.
Let's just make sure
that it's working.
We've got here shard number two.
And now, when we run tests,
we see that updates on-prem
are no longer expected.
So that's where we don't want
that data to move anymore.
I'm going to deploy my code.
And now, it's still all
fine, because we are not
moving any data to
shard two because we
changed the application.
Now let's simulate
our rogue application,
the one that we forgot in
the data center that is going
to update shard number two.
What I'm going do
here is I'm going
to insert a new transaction
to the on-prem databases
for shard number two, which
is not supposed to happen.
And then we'll see
how we deal with it.
That's what I did.
And while that is populating,
I actually want to show you
another nice element, which is
a live visualization of the data
stream itself.
So part of the Alooma
product is the ability
to visualize everything that's
coming in from the data stream
live.
So we can see the source.
You can filter on
the data itself.
You can even see the
events themselves.
And this is looking nice
and also very useful
for [? gut checks. ?] Now
this is a more high volume
system that's actually
storing data in live.
I can filter on only events that
are coming from IOS or mobile,
for example.
I can actually see those events.
Except being a nice eye
candy, it's also very useful
just for [? a gut check. ?]
Am I getting
what I'm expecting to get?
Is that data really make sense?
So going back to our
rogue application
that updated the shard, by now,
we have already read that data.
And what you can see is we
have wrong data in what you
call the restream queue.
So this is where
we handle errors.
We can see what happened.
You got an event.
That event says shard two.
That's not supposed to happen.
We did something bad.
We still have an application.
We need to find out where it
is, which server does it sit in,
why is it writing those events
into my old on-prem database.
So that's part of
our validation step.
And I can actually find out
exactly which application
that is, what is it writing.
It makes it very easy for me.
In fact, I actually
have the sample.
And the data itself makes it
very easy for me to find out.
And once I'm
satisfied with it, I'm
just going to say, OK, I
found that application.
I can either purge
the data back,
or I can just purge all of
this data and throw it away.
I'm saying, all right,
now, I've successfully
migrated that shard.
I can move on to migrate
the other shard well.
So this was a very
simple use case
of lift-and-shift
migration, of taking data
from MySQL and the source.
And again, we already
saw a couple of snags
that you can hit while only
doing that very simple lift
and shift.
Again, when you're moving
your real enterprise data set,
it has thousands of tables
with terabytes of data.
That, of course, can
be much more complex.
And then once you do that,
it's also very simple
to do life and modernize
instead of lift and shift.
So I will take that MySQL.
I just replace it with
Spanner exactly the same say.
Even I move to Cloud SQL.
Now I'm putting Cloud
SQL there in the source.
And I'm putting Spanner
here in the target.
And all of the sudden, I
can tell a thousand x more
transaction volume.
[MUSIC PLAYING]